so the way that we have framed the
conversation that we'll be having here
this evening is on the premise that
identity politics has become ever more
influential the left championing
identity is based on sexuality and race
while the right is reasserting the
nation does our desire to belong to one
tribe or another make conflict with
others inevitable could we do away with
tribal allegiances and see ourselves as
part of the same human family or a group
identities based on class race sexuality
or nationality the only effective
vehicles for political change so I'll
introduce each of the panelists first up
Phillip blonde political philosopher
anglican theologian and director of the
respect and also here with a storm
Butler Labour MP representing Brent
central has served as shadow women and
equalities secretary since 2017 and
David Blunkett of course one of the most
respected members of Tony Blair's
cabinet having held many cabinet
positions Education Secretary Home
Secretary and Work and Pensions
secretary and since leaving politics in
May 2015 has worked in academia and for
charities okay well we will hear first
of all from Philipp Lahm what is
happening in the West from America
through through out sort of Western and
Eastern Europe it it's a fragmentation
and a breakdown and the successful
parties are no longer to be understood
on the left-right spectrum they're
actually a mixture of left and right
there are socialists who believe in
leave there are socialists who believe
in remain but leave and remain are now
better predictors of who you're going to
vote for than your past tribal identity
so what's really happening is is
realignment and fragmentation and
largely speaking I want to suggest to
you that the formulation that's taking
place and I think you know you you got
it in one is nationalism on the one hand
and extreme liberalism understood as
identity politics on the other
and I won't suggest you that neither of
them ultimately in my view will work
because we have been governed by extreme
liberalism for really since since the
time of Margaret Thatcher have extreme
economic liberalism on the right extreme
social liberalism on the left and there
a common project and I always think it's
incoherent to hear people on the left's
denouncing neoliberalism economically
but essentially upholding it socially
and and vice versa so what is the
liberal project that is now over the
liberal project is essentially a grand
global project of extreme individualism
and this grand global project have first
appealed to the narcissism of the 1960s
and the genuine injustice --is that the
1960s spoke to but what it creates is a
dispensation economically that only
favors those at the very very top if you
look at the global distribution the
famous elephant graph by Branko
Milanovic he shows that really over the
last 3040 years has been no net gain for
the vast majority of the working
population from globalization and the
gain has been for the working class in
the third world whereas the working
class and increasing the middle class in
the first world has seen no genuine gain
at all you've seen the rise of rampant
insecurity because insecurity stems from
Brampton to individualism and we've
created on the economic level forms of
insecurity that we're actually
unthinkable in the 60s or indeed the 70s
but on the cultural right and culture we
know outcompetes economics in any
assessment of human behavior liberalism
has essentially created a culture that
oppresses majorities that creates
marginalize majorities through identity
politics that are little more than
middle-class power games and attempts by
middle class advocates to both virtue
signal and gain power
within a medium whereby solidarity has
collapsed so don't be surprised that
nationalism is on the way back because
nationalism by those who advocate for it
is the only thing that will care for
them nationalism by it from the
perspective it's of advocates is the
only thing that will care for those who
have lost out whereas liberalism won't
liberalism of of the extreme left has
become an upper-middle class project and
so what we've got is a project where
solidarity are looking after us all has
been captured by nationalism and the
project the right wing project of
extreme individualism is now followed by
both left-wing parties and right-wing
parties that is the new divide that is
the new debate that is where we are so
for me I feel that this is a real sort
of academic debate and not one that I
totally agree with its concept and it's
all about identity politics because you
know politics has always been about
identity me growing up as a as a black
woman will have very different identity
to two other people growing up
themselves and there in their social
environment so I think the main thing is
that politics should make sense and
should be about policies and I think
that's the main basis that we should
start from I mean every human being is
molded by the society that they've grown
up in your molded by how you grew up who
spoke to you the biases that you have
growing up that's that's who we are so
you will fight the different things I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that the problem is that not all
identities are the same so I think as we
start to dismantle all the social
barriers that contribute to the
disparities in society that's when
people start saying oh my god identity
politics is bad because you are you are
taken away my privilege all of a sudden
and you want to take some of my
privilege away and I don't like it the
whole term identity poly
it just means we are doing politics and
I need to I need to fight for things
that I believe in because that's where
my passion is and if you want to call it
identity politics call it that okay well
um in March I was blagged into doing
something for comic relief with David
Williams and I had to stand up and swing
left woods and say ladies I still swing
to the left and I still swing to the
left and I'm tribal in political terms
tribalism in this sense meaning having a
real sense of identity with the people
that I've worked with that I've grown up
with that I share values with and even
when we are in conflict with each other
about ideas or direction we still have a
sense of that common purpose so there
can be tribalism that actually is a glue
that holds people together in a positive
sense and there can be identity and
nationalism which is narrow and
exclusive and anything but what in the
jargon would be called civic Republic
ism so I believe in mutuality and
reciprocity of trying to put the glue
back in so that people do feel a sense
of belonging a sense that they have some
identity with the people around them and
that they will care about them as the as
you would with an extended family and
that's not to do with borders or
language or faith or even culture it's
to do with how people see each other and
work with each other I think that the
danger at the moment and Phillip has
touched on it and I heard dawn earlier
mentioning it before we came in is the
idea that our identity is exclusive to
particular aspects of our life or
background identity of gender or sexual
orientation or faith or of disability
seems to me to be extremely dangerous
because it separates out by people's
very
specific elements within them rather
than that they have that common
citizenship and coming together and
maybe we'd like to debate that because I
find it really disturbing that people
want to categorize by things that should
not separate us
I've therefore in favor of patriotism in
the George Orwell sense rather than
nationalism I'm in favor of putting the
glue back in in building from the
community think global act local so that
people do feel that they've got
something in common and finding things
that unites rather than dividers and
doing that builds a different sort of
sense of identity and belonging and a
different kind of tribalism to what we
see at the moment which deliberately
seeks to separate deliberately plays on
people's worst instincts deliberately
intends to build up resentment and
dislike an often hatred about other
people and in the end that has to mean
that we get people to feel that they've
got something real in common rather than
that what divides them is the thing that
identifies and separates and creates
that identity all of our panelists
Philipp Lahm Don Butler David Blunkett
[Applause]